elles ont fait les choses en vrai
franchement c'est du bon soit il s'est
fait il est chaud lui à partir au
baptême spacek
une série qui fait c'est franck
gastambide et réalisateur dans aussi tu
sais comme le futur homme de ma vie il
est pas mal c'est vrai c'est validé
exactement
bon allez validé allez je suis braquée
l'industrie michael jamais pas en dire
déjà ça a commencé avec du bon son fait
mais dans l'ambiance dès qu'il prend du
point friendster big machine bien
comment ils ont tourné ça ils ont fait
comme siaka cameron d'un brouillon mais
c'est hatikva mais ce qu'il fait on voit
jamais l'envers du décor sur le wrapping
c'est cool tu attrapes cependant on va
découvrir cet album qui sort dans une
quinzaine de jours
l'animateur attend lui laisser difool
mon attention c'est pas difficile avec
l'annoncé très détendu en équipe
toujours en exil on est là on est en
famille pas drive a été assez ipc drives
et nous avons monsieur dj am et à lucho
de gestion d'assaut en fait il ya
vraiment tout le monde et est reconnu
que son envie de l'impression que c'est
le manager du mec qui joue dans la série
je regarde toutes les séries ça va
rare de voir et lui je connais lune il a
joué dans profession tequila jouer le
0-0 ce fait les séries car en fait d'un
problème qu'est ce qu'il ya je parle de
venir voir si tout se passe bien parce
que la drac scellier raf drogue tout ça
veut pas juste concentré dans sa musique
au lieu de faire des trucs comme ça
le rhin la con samou la comédie vitesse
donc il va pas faire du cliché qu'est ce
qu'il a encore fait qu'andy bas
tu sais faire du véhicule avec la
bagarre avec la crim boubakary ce futur
octobre on peut être avec mes sont
battus à l'aéroport sa balle aura bien à
oued accorde un coup d'essai en option
chez vous de la femme de franck lors
dans la vraie vie elle a trop de charges
celle ci va envoyer samedi ouazzani
pascal un débit de paroles qui peut pas
encaisser une chose qu'elle joue trop
bien non c'est sûr les gauchos les
agrafes du monde ce soir ça au bordel
c'est pas possible sauf si je te fais un
match après ces trucs à lui et sur la
côte non je ne connais pas comment ça tu
beaucoup de quoi il sa famille qu'il va
se faire défoncer vendu moitié est ce
que c'est vraiment tu dois livrer un
concert comme ça on serait des ce film
plein de filles qui a vu durant et
sympathique un premier coup de fil qui
ne vivent un million de questions me
viennent en tête
il a eu l'opportunité de voir à se
montrer malin quand même à aller sans
nous quelque chose de tout à fait ce que
personne n'a fait faut dire que tu
portais cool toi j'te kiffe l'été un
fils de respecte je rester courtois mais
atteint donc payer cher il avait bu mais
regardez le rappeur deuxième tranche à
mozart minute sur un but important
qu'aujourd'hui la 32e mais il a osé te
dire que tu as vous sentez la ces
données il est chez lui
allez salut terminé tu sais très bien
est né dans son salon leur était devant
moi leur béguin
moi je sais pas comment salon les gars
un show haut en bas
très forte image et ils sont obligés de
le faire mais c'est peut-être l'occasion
de lui montrer un petit peu ce que tu
vaux maintenant non qu'est ce que t'en
pense savoir ap sa lancée par ap sec
avec des amis à petit orteil dans la
cour des grands à là c'était bien fait
quand même le coup du téléphone
musicalement ça tu peux nous disent tous
ça ces mecs des charentais
malgré le fait un buzz goffi ça irait à
faire repérer et tout et après avoir
signé hier la star qui fait novateur
pour lancement l'album ça chauffe
je peux vous emmener où la star ayant
mal tourné après easy peut-être qu'il va
rencontrer des stars huit bébés william
easterly de planter là alors c'est pas
grave tu enchaînes je continuerai c'est
le bonus de les filles ira pas il sait
pas ce qui va nourrir et puis quoi du
vélo tu vois un nom est de m'obliger
juin à tpm peux tu faire des accents
tous à la crise
donc maintenant d'un problème à la crim
à la crème il va lui prendre sur saône
elle parce que je qu'il en classe avec l
excuse moi on préfère un petit autorités
à ces mecs 213 m et ses frères l'emca et
du caméo quoi du coup avec moi ça on a
une idée on voulait proposer
d'enregistrer un feat
si ça chauffe
des thèmes pour sa part qu'à pêcher
comme un brasseur j'ai fait ça le hit de
l'été dans mon beau serge est la cocue
avait compté somme à ce même genou c'est
du bon son ils sont partis direct
travailleurs ça va vite après
essentielle pour avoir un mec c'est bien
[Applaudissements]
une prise le mec c'est eminem salut les
amis j'espère que tout se passe bien
réunir garde ici t'es chez moi donc tu
peux pas de ferme ta gueule pour les
postes de son trafic et tous ces bons et
on va commencer à faire les gars ils
reviennent de là aussi peuvent
comprendre c'est moi qui payais sa
première mixtape à lui et on peut jeter
des grains de rouge et montereau frérot
vous arrêter comme ça c'est un milieu
qu'on connaît pas alors à plein de guest
c'était trop stylé franchement c'est un
homme allait trop bien sa série moi je
les vallées vertes en servant à les
rappeler dur là on va se faire un
concert de booba bombe à franck